the heaviest complicit transformations
and you member transformations right
it's actually short for there's a
two-word phrase we learnt yesterday
member was also starts for the seat on
gülen's yes okay so all it means is a
way that you can change shape so that
it's still absolutely the same shape
same size all that kind of thing okay
now we learned that there were three of
them we did a big nice table we took a
long time look going through it what
were the three was the first one and you
take us yes ah yeah well okay we'll go
to the second one that's again
reflection which is like flipping or
Mary okay Ali translation was the first
one we looked at though really I suppose
you could do them in any order and what
does a stood in for translation yeah
well someone else went Nova Elina yeah
good sliding or shifting around okay I'm
the very last one I'm not rotation
excellent which is about spinning or
turning okay now very simply all this
idea of called mr. transformations is
well what we say come for center what
does that mean opposite you James's war
it does actually it does sound like
opposite doesn't it but meet something a
little bit different you take the F what
ah
you're thinking of like prime numbers
and composite numbers you're getting to
it what my composite mean as a general
term hmm I think what it refers to is
what you've got many things composed
together like you know if you compose a
novel thing like that it's like putting
a whole bunch of words together or a
composite number it's lots of numbers
lots of factors go into it okay so
copies of transformations is where you
do a whole bunch of these one after
another so to show you what that looks
like
why don't you draw yourself a triangle
make it a look look a bit like mine and
we're going to do more than one
transformation after another so maybe
we'll go with let's go with a reflection
and then a rotation here's the way we're
gonna do it
remember each of that
formations requires ingredients right
well with the ingredients for a
reflection what do we need yeah whoa do
we need a direction for reflection oh
right a straight line good okay so I'm
gonna yeah so we are going to reflect
this triangle across this straight line
okay now to make this a little more easy
for us he's all I got to do let's name
this triangle we'll call it
triangle ABC and this line let's call it
say line L that's my lowercase L I'm
doing it with a loop in it so you don't
confuse it with the number one okay so
the first thing we're going to do first
is we're going to reflect and this is
the way I would write it reflect
triangle a B C across line L okay that's
the first thing that we're going to do
okay then find that I'm gonna do speak
another transmission I'm gonna go with
rotation I think that's a bit more
interesting than translation I'm going
to put now what were the ingredients for
a rotation we need a straight line for
reflection and there we go
okay what any grease is quite a few yeah
I can't we need an angle a size of angle
in some number of degrees what else do
we need apart from an angle yeah I can't
we need a point like where where are we
looking okay I think there's one more
yes hon oh I think we said angle right
what do we have on top of a oh yeah yeah
good we're under clockwise or
anti-clockwise
okay so there's three things right so a
point we need a point let's put the
point under put it
okay so I'm gonna call that P right so
what you're going to do is first we'll
do the reflection yeah good question I'm
doing an opposite aim so we're a is
going to be sorry it should actually be
a bit further so you see where he is
right so go all the way across to there
and we'll make that P okay so sorry
again first reflection second we're
going to rotate now do you remember I
said at the very end of the lesson right
that when you've got a shape and it's
been transformed your we've got the
original and then what's this called
what's the thing called after you do the
it depends on what I mean for all the
translations yeah it means very good
we're going to get the image over here
okay so what we're gonna do is were take
the image okay of the triangle and we're
going to rotate it let's see what should
we do let's go 90 degrees clockwise so
you can see that there's two pieces in
angle and a direction about the point P
okay it will really help if you use a
ruler to do because then it'll be nice
and accurate all that kind of thing okay
you should have borrowed one before you
can collect one in a second all right
let's give this a go okay now I have my
other color with me
all right we will do saw it first step
now you will need not just the straight
edge but actually something that you can
okay so you've got your measures on
there do you remember how do we do the
reflection and make sure it's accurate
say none remember yeah good good do it
okay so I'm gonna get my ruler right and
I'm gonna go it's directly to the line
okay now yours might be a bit of a
different distance obviously mine is
huge
so I see that as 12 centimeters there
that line there okay cuz you know it's a
big diagram okay so I'm gonna go 12
centimeters there okay
so those should be the same they're the
same length okay now what I'm not is
I've got one point I'm gonna do one at a
time okay
so this new point I had over here okay
I'm gonna call it well this is a B and C
so I'm gonna call this it came from B
I'm gonna call it b1
okay yes there will be a bit too shortly
okay so there's b1 I'll do the same for
C okay and you can um you can see you're
gonna get something very similar aren't
you okay again I'm going directly to the
line okay so yeah the question because
we're going to do a rotation after this
make sense so there's two
transformations that's what makes it a
composite transformation
okay so I've measured my distance here
see and so should you
and when you go across you're gonna get
a new point over here and to distinguish
it from the original ones it's called
that c1 c1 okay so far so good
I just had that one point left and if I
measure across well my intention is that
actually ends up with P so P is also
it's also a one speaker all right so now
I've got three points in the original
triangle three points for the image
triangle let's draw the image okay
should look like this okay how do we
look does that look at that right are
you happy with that
okay cool so there you go there's your
first step we've done our reflection of
triangle ABC across the line L now I
couldn't do the rotation okay so this is
a bit tricky how do I do this okay each
of these points are going to rotate and
they're gonna go this way this way okay
so I'm gonna start with on a1 and b1
right see this line here it's line here
or marketing green for you the reason
why I pick a line is because we're good
at knowing how lines are a tape right
like if you look at a clock you can see
how the lines are at a and the point
that they're attending around is what's
the center of the clock isn't it okay
so I want you to picture a 1 or P rather
as the center of the clock and this
Green Line is going to rotate 90 degrees
clockwise 90 we clockwise so here's what
you're going to need and then doing
green okay I'm you're going to need to
measure this length of this this line
okay
now buy one is it's about 14 centimeters
long obviously you also be a bit smaller
than that okay but when we rotate it
those 90 degrees it's gonna go around
like this okay QC it's going clockwise
so should end up something like this
maybe I've done lesson speak so you can
see it okay so can you see he was the
original line and now it's being rotated
and there's that 90 degrees that's
actually I can find angle in there isn't
it
okay sir thank you there's um that was a
1 that was B 1 so what should we call
this point call it B - that's a good
good name I think I shall leave it is um
I'll leave this baby ok excellent
now I've got another line that I can
rotate right can you see it
you got some choices I could rotate this
line here like you see that where's it
going to go it's gonna it's gonna come
around isn't it just like another arm of
the clock right something like this do
you see that okay so you'll want to know
what's the length of that long side
there okay you want to measure yours my
one is 2770 very long okay but it's
gonna come around in the sandwich so
it's something like this okay there you
go so you can see now I've rotated two
of them that was B - what should I call
this wait is it eight okay from see it
came from C that's okay all right yes
not calling for now I'm almost done I've
actually got all the points I need done'
all I have to do is connect this up and
there's my triangle
tada okay so there you go there's my
composit transformation from the red all
the way to the green that was in okay
and that was the instructions that we
followed